it's a tough gig being a pollinator
these days especially in big cities land
is being used differently and that's a
threat to pollinating insects but a new
study of four UK cities shows that
increasing urbanization doesn't have to
be a death sentence a team of ecologists
looked at nine types of land-use that
make up most of a city's area if you
exclude buildings roads and water which
aren't much used to pollinators anyway
first they counted the total number of
pollinators and plants in each area
recording how many different species
there were as well the more numerous and
varied the plants the greater the
biodiversity of pollinators no surprises
there gardens held the most and most
varied pollinating insects but not all
garden plants are equally appealing
hydrangeas daisies and forget-me-nots
were less appetizing whereas among
pollinators favorite flowers where
dandelions brambles and buttercups ones
that gardeners often pull up next the
researchers wanted to know how land
could be better managed to support
pollinator communities so they built a
computer model to test how giving more
land to each different land use might
make pollinator networks more robust in
other words more resilient to species
loss they found that the biggest bounce
in robustness came when they allotted
more space to allotments even though
with the boost
allotments still only accounted for less
than 1% of City space allotments host
fruits vegetables and weeds as well a
mix which provides a great variety of
flowers the researchers also wondered if
there were other ways to boost the
robustness of pollinator communities
according to their model this could be
achieved by planting more flowers in
parks and allowing wildflowers to grow
in verges and other green spaces a few
simple strategies see the researchers
could help support pollinators in cities
across the world
add more allotments plant flowers in
parks and don't know that grass
[Music]